alors on va vous privé de la vue un de
la vue on va vous amener des objets et
au toucher vous allez nous dire ce que
c'est
alors moi je ne vais pas non l'accusé
jours pour vous et fera pas mathieu
comme objet c'est pas vous qui décidez
allez mettez ça est ce qu'on peut
emmener les objets s'il vous plaît à la
hâte en syrienne dégâts non non rien vu
à la télé on va voir simplement si vous
avez dû toucher ça m'a alors dit kane
facile et des choses humaines
[Rires]
ouais
parce que tu crois toi tu es moi c'est
électrique d'un sextoy
non je savais c'est un fer à lisser
utilise pas tous les jours donc alors la
voie la baule non la merde je veux
sentir si elle essayait santé gouttes
boîte et j'ai maintenant écoutez pas
coûter pas que t'es pas et rillettes du
mans non c'est la chair à saucisse et
pas mal de publicité assez bas alors peu
ouais ben serviette on y voit touchée on
l'a perdue depuis nécessaires soient
bénins mais on en a appris beaucoup plus
moment-là et un dernier enfin
normalement ça est facile pour ben oui
le martinet
[Applaudissements]